good morning
Millennials [__] PSA [__] PSA T up
what's going on tury L what's going on
is that today we are joined by Tik Tock
sensation good friend might I add Jake
Shane you might know him as octopus
lover eight an eight Hey Jake how you
ding girl I'm good I'm [__] tired but
I'm done I'm so excited for you to be
here this is like our third or fourth
time I will say like I did have to
reschedule and I'm so sorry wait it's so
fine but you're so worth the wait Jake
oh my God you're worth the wait we're
worth the wait okay yeah I obsessed with
you I have followed you on Tik Tok like
not to make everything about me but like
I feel like I saw something in you early
like I feel like I was an early Tik Tok
follow of yours you're an early [__]
early I was an early [__] and you have
just blown up over the last what like
six months six months I think exactly
six months how many Tik Tok followers do
you currently have um let me think 2.4
2.4 million so like jealous and not even
like a little happy for you I'm just
jealous you know yeah I am the most
jealous person in life by the way
normalize being jealous normalize
[__] being jealous I'm so jealous and
bitter about everything no like whenever
I see like other people doing things I'm
like why isn't that me why isn't that me
that should be me holding your hands oh
you have a nice voice oh my God thank
you okay so you blew up on Tik Tok now
of course we're literally like the
official podcast of Tik Tok so everybody
here like pretty much knows but we know
we we do have you know a bit of an older
crew Instagram reals listeners so for
those who may not be familiar tell us
your story Jake okay so like like my
life story or like no like your career
like your career story okay so basically
I was at USC and I was taking like I was
interning at a record label and I had
like a year off before I could like like
my internship was over and like I
couldn't start full-time so they were
like okay like do something do something
and I was like okay so I was like
leaning into like college and then I was
like I'm really bored and I was at my
friend's mom's birthday dinner and the
octopus came and I'm like oh my God this
is just like such a perfect time like
the octopus is in the dish yeah the puss
came the puss came okay and I was like I
need to I turned to my best friend Alice
I was like I need to like start this P
the puss thing so I tried to set up P
the puss P the puss was taken dead and I
was like weird and then I did pass that
puss which like has a better ring to it
anyway like not bitter pass that puss
and I started basically just posting
photos of octopus and raing them out of
eight tentacles and then I like started
posting like videos kind of and one
night something just came to me where I
was like oh my God you should like do a
call and respond yeah and so I did that
and then like I didn't really think
anything of it I literally had like 50
followers and then like one person came
up to me on a night out at like the
college bar and I was like oh so like I
have fans oh so you remember the first
time you were approached oh yes her name
is Alexis I remember too I don't
remember the person's name I was too
busy thinking about myself
and how my life was about to change no
that I literally got home and I was like
uh so I want everyone to know I have a
fan and everyone was like making fun of
me and now look at me now I'm on the
toes no literally everyone can eat your
[__] ass literally I'm so glad you
remember that moment cuz it's kind of
it's like it's a transition transitional
phase where like somebody who doesn't
know you recognizes you I was in a
casino and this person was like are you
like and I honestly it was really
embarrassing cuz I was at like a table
with like gamblers and they were like
what is going on and I was like honestly
sir please don't talk to me but it was
like so sick and so I'm glad you
recognize that and then how much longer
until from that moment until you really
blew up brand deals millions of
followers like how long how long did it
actually take I want to say after that I
think that was in January so maybe like
a year and two months wow that's fast
yeah so I kept posting on Instagram I
like didn't really like do the only Tik
Tok I had to my name was um this
reaction with me and my two friends
Brett and Julia to all to well 10minute
version which Taylor actually commented
on stop yeah I was really excited I was
in my friend apartment and I was
screaming I'm sorry you were in your
friend whose apartment Trudy her name is
Trudy L Trudy L you have a best friend
named trudo yeah she's actually here
yeah I know
hey um okay so your life pretty much
changed overnight I feel like this
happens a lot with Tik tokers like when
when Remy Bader first came on the toast
I think for like other creators or just
people in the public space there's a a
slow Arc you know you get momentum and
it's then it slowly grows but Tik Tok
has this nature where people's lives
really change in such a short amount of
time and I think it can be really hard
for people it's really fun if you can
handle it but I think there's obviously
like a really dark side to it so I'm
curious like how your lifechanging
really on a dime has been for you like
have you struggled with it or is it all
fun in games no I've definitely
struggled like I was like well because I
had I'm such a planner so like I had
like my plan in my mind like I was like
I was going up like I was gaining
followers like slowly but shortly like
but so I was like slowly but shortly
help slowly but surely slowly but surely
I'm done and I was like loving I
literally thought I was like the most
famous person in the world it's so crazy
like what you can concoct in your own
mind when you're so obsessed with
yourself no I mean the Story of My Life
yes Story Of My Life I take her home I
drive all night to keep her warm inside
don't be afraid it's
frozen continue that was awesome um I
had like 60,000 followers and I was
celebrating 60,000 followers it's huge
yeah and I was like oh my god let's do
my favorite thing and let's um have
everyone tell me I'm a good actor so
comment St if you want me to act out got
it and I wasn't and I was honestly like
I was really high and I was like [__] I
promised the [__] I would do this and
I like I don't have it in me right now
like I can't I can't pull this like Bill
Clinton impress impression out of me
like I can't do it so I like spoke like
this as Bill Clinton and people like
really thought it was funny and then so
I kept kind of rolling with that and it
I got a million followers in a week in a
week yeah and I was like that's so crazy
it was crazy well honestly I remember
just watching it like at a vantage point
your video it's really crazy how like
the Tik Tok Al algorithm when it works
for you like it'll serve you to everyone
and it was I felt like in a matter of
hours you were everywhere no it was
crazy and but the thing is I thought
that that's just how Tik Tok worked with
everyone so I was like thinking no it's
not trust some of us are out here trying
so hard for this 300,000 followers no
but I thought like all like the Tik Tok
people like I thought it like that just
cuz like Charlie has like a 100 million
followers I just thought like I wasn't
really thinking that hard but I was
obviously like so excited and then
obviously you're like it's like and then
it's just like okay it's your job right
overnight it becomes just like a a
career yeah well because the guy I was
the assistant for is now my manager
right so it was like a really quick okay
turn turn around and he was like I will
do this for you let me ask you another
question so I put you in the category of
people who like blew up overnight with
with like Emily Maro right Alex Earl yes
do Emily and Alex have a group chat like
have you I've never spoken to Emily I
feel like nobody's spoken to Emily hash
where's Emily Maro I know she was on her
honeymoon and everybody like thought she
died cuz she didn't post for two weeks
and she's like hey guys I'm here I'm
just like actually living my life not on
my phone see you soon respect so you
guys don't chat they never so funny you
say that though because two years ago my
memory was me eating the Emily Moro
salmon Bowl did you like it it was
[__] insane but my stomach hurt so
badly After hot take it was one of the
most disgusting
in my life having said that like it's
not for me I don't enjoy like salmon and
Mayo yeah it was I tolerate salmon I
definitely don't eat Mayo yeah it was
you don't like Mayo no it's like a kind
of a big deal between me and my husband
my husband would put mayo like seriously
on a cracker like he would eat it okay
that's disgusting he would eat it he got
roasted the other day cuz he put um Mayo
on his hot dog that's [__] nasty in
his defense he said he was making
Russian so we didn't see like because I
had taken a video of him and people were
like is that Mayo he was putting ketchup
on top and going to mix it like to make
Russian
yeah no my husband's disgusting like one
of the most disgusting people I've ever
met in my life oh my God that's nasty
yeah on a hot dog he'll put it on
anything and then like when we first
started dating he roasted me cuz like we
I was over at his place we had like Dr
drank the night before and so before he
woke up I was ordering Bagels cuz I was
[__] starving and I didn't really
like know his orders for stuff yet but I
know he loved tuna so I got him tuna and
they were like do you want to add stuff
and I added a bunch of stuff like
lettuce pickle um Russian there was
Russian on the thing so I was like yeah
sure Russian he loves Mayo he was like
did you put Russian in my bagel I'm like
is that crazy he's like he still talks
about it to this day I'm like you're
disgusting you eat everything you're
literally a vacuum I'm weird for getting
Russian on your tuna that's not weird
it's not weird given what you eat you
eat Mayo on a hot dog how is I feel like
a bagel's the least weird thing to put
Russian on that's like bread for a
sandwich thank you I guess the tuna made
it weird why there's literally Mayo in
tuna thank you thank you I'm team you
for this one I gu ketchup no I I stand
by what I did yeah you should because
that's the least weird thing ever how do
we get here here oh Emily Maro sa right
yeah I don't know where she is but her
wedding was [__] Chic so stunning
like so stunning like that dress was
everything she's so Timeless she's so
Timeless I love her I [__] love Emily
Maro and I miss her every day I know I'm
wishing her well though in her you know
newly wed Bliss yeah so there's no group
chat but I'm sure you've spoken to like
other creators who have kind of I speak
to Al oh yeah and you guys have like a
similar Journey like similar obviously
like hers is like me times a million no
she's like at Paris fashion weekend not
yeah exactly first of all first of all
Fashion Week is a [__] lie because
this [__] has been going on for a
[__] month yeah it's they call it
fashion month I hate it no I was just
thinking about that this morning too
because Fashion Week has become New York
Fashion Week I'm only speaking about has
kind of become this like commercialized
like brand deal it's not really like
about fashion no it's not and I think
that if you really want to see like who
is like a real mover and Shaker in the
fashion industry when it comes to like
the influencer community look who's
going to like Paris fashion week because
everyone can go to New York Fashion Week
it's kind of like a free-for-all
Coachella these it is Coachella but
Paris F week is like still very in Paris
they're like no we you guys can't go
right like Zena is there right so if
you're being invited and flowing out
like that's like real creme de crem and
I think it's really interesting to see
like who actually goes and who I know oh
[__] Paris fashion week is the one I
live for but they all make me really
insecure if I'm going to be honest do
okay that's another good question you've
blown up you're getting invited places
it's really hard not to compare yourself
to other people and like what we were
talking about jealousy like what are
other people doing what brand deals are
they trips are how do you deal with like
minimizing that type of like negative
talk in your brain
um like I just have my friends yell at
me love that for you like I'll like
speak and they'll be like shut up I'm
literally working at 9 to5 well you know
what I want to ask you that because the
last time we well spoke in person we
went out for dinner and you were
updating me on everything and you were
still working a full-time job yes and
that was like a conscious choice you had
made what are you doing now now I'm
doing this full-time okay now I'm doing
this full-time but I did that for as
long as I could because it really kept
me grounded like going into an office
every day like really just like I don't
know it made this feel a little more
normal that's why everyone was like has
your life changed I'm like well I hang
out with the same people and I do the
same thing I just like post like a few
videos like for brand deals yeah and
like I get to go to like cool stuff on
cuz I was like I would like go to that
stuff sometimes cuz I worked on the
other side of the industry yeah I would
work I would go as like a as to work
work the event as opposed to like be a
talent there so like that's that would
be the that was different but um yeah
now I'm doing this full-time which it's
honestly like it's been a little like
leaning into it fully is a lot easier on
my head cuz like when you were when I
was working a full-time job and I was
doing this it was like literally Hannah
Montana how do you prioritize yeah yeah
and I was like what's happening like I'm
literally getting high and bed at 3:00
a.m. and making a video that gets a
million views and then like going waking
up at six and no okay so that's good
it's also really scary to like let go of
everything that up until this point was
like stable for you and you know what
what you're told you should do which is
you know graduate get a job so to let
that go I totally understand that it was
crazy I'm like what am I doing and it's
also like Tik Tok is so scary because
everyone's like oh my God this is so
amazing but it's like okay but your
entire career is kind of based on what
people think of you and it is [__]
scary okay so let's talk about that yeah
first of all I feel like relatively and
maybe it's just cuz my bar is high cuz
I've like you know been canceled a
thousand times I feel like you your
situation doesn't look that bad but
again that's just my outside perspective
like do you get hate like sometime well
I just like read all the comments so
like one time like I posted like the
other day I posted like oh my God I like
literally can't even hear myself speak
it makes me want to throw up and someone
commented it's almost as bad as looking
at you no I was I hate when they get
like creative with like a really good
SLE cuz it's like you want to be mad but
like they really got you you no one time
someone so mean you're so good-looking
like everyone can eat your ass but when
like commenters have SASS and like you
know how to use language it really it
hurts even more oh one time someone
commented I was like upset about like
these two gay people dating cuz like I'm
not dating anyone and I was like yeah
jealousy jealous jealousy mhm I don't
know the rest of the lyrics El NE or
else I would sing it with you it's like
you go out every night all your friends
they go out every night and daddy's nice
car okay yeah you living the life and
your girlfriend's Prett pretty
two yeah we got it okay so somebody once
commented so somebody once commented G I
know but like they only date
10 and what about it and I was like okay
so I'm not and then you want to know the
most insulting comment I would love to
they thought they
ate for me the equivalent of they
thought they ate is yikes ooh I got a
yikes the other day and I was like o no
when people like use it not ironically
like I say yikes like as a joke normal
when people who are like yikes seriously
eat my ass grab a spoon and eat my
[__] ass [__] like seriously yeah go
away um okay so you're out here and for
those who may not be familiar two of the
things you really popularized and
invented in Tik Tok culture
is the act it out where people will
leave you suggestions like act out you
know ablink and finding out that Andrew
Jackson is one or whoever the [__] is on
the $1 bill and you kind of recreate
like historical events which is
hysterical are you like is history a
particular interest of yours it's like
an interest of like my mom and my
brother and so like maybe that's why but
like like it honestly only happened
because like with Tik Tok like when like
like I literally just throw [__] at the
wall like you're like boiling pasta and
like seeing if it's done or seeing if it
sticks and I was like so I got the
acting out idea from Julia Fox she would
like take suggestions in the comments
like tell me what to act out and so
someone commented like do this do this
do this and then someone commented do
Bill Clinton with Monica linsk Linsky or
whatever and I did it in like a funny
way and I was like oo that's funny so
then I kept taking historical stuff and
doing it and was like you know so much
about history I'm like no like I know
what the comment said and like that's
Google it like and I'll Google it no me
and Jackie always have this conversation
something I'm really trying to get
better at it's like be like a little bit
more learned like I literally went to
college and I know nothing about history
it's embarrassing so now I've started to
read historical fiction I think that's
like a really good way to start learning
but Jackie was like asking me a bunch of
questions on the podcast like a year or
two ago and she was these are like basic
History questions like what okay and I
didn't know half of them and now I want
to see if you know them what started or
like what was the Catalyst for World War
I World War I is so irrelevant like we
all know we all know World War II like
um World War I I'll give you a clue this
is the clue Jackie gave me it was the
assassination of someone
oh my God yes it was wasn't it
some I feel like you're going to say
something right some treaty no okay Arch
Duke FR Ferdinand who the [__] is that
precisely my response and even though
I've like committed to learning more
about history I still I'm focused on
World War II World War II is so much
more interesting World War II is like
it's like a movie World War I we don't
know her I don't know what happened in
World War I actually at all but all I
know is that Germany was down bad yeah
and they stayed down bad and they came
back with aention like killed everyone
and I love reading about World War II
honestly because I usually read about
like I'm trying to figure out I I I know
from like a Jewish perspective like
obviously about the Holocaust and I know
a lot about the Holocaust but I don't
really know about the war and how it
impacted the different countries in
Europe so I read you know the nighting
Gale which took place in France then I
just read this book about Italy so I'm
like learning about what life was like
in under like Nazi occupation in those
in those regions um what point was I
trying to make that you know about
history because you're reading because
I'm reading I was about to make a fire
point I can't remember um okay another
history question that Jackie had asked
me and I actually knew the answer too
what year was the
Titanic
19 I'm going to make something up yeah
1907 so close 1912 okay so close and I
only knew that because of Downtown Abby
downt starts with the Titanic in 192 you
know I've never seen the Titanic the
movie yeah okay like I saw when I was a
kid and I was like oh this is so sad why
am I watching this movie and yeah it's
like I think it's a movie we should
watch like watch it with you yeah yeah
don't know if I could watch it with you
cuz like you would make me laugh and
it's supposed to be sad H but like
whatever whatever right like it's
Leonardo Dicaprio and he's so hot so
true like day one Leo he was so hot back
then so sorry I still think he's hot
um I don't I know but there's something
about him that I'm just like yeah I'm
you you oh I I'm not experiencing the
same phenomena but that's what's so
great about the toast like we're we're
giving platforms to people with
different opinions it's 100% and you're
a big Pup Culture fan you're a big
toaster the yes so you're going to do
the Fast Five with me today I'm so
excited and you're an enormous Swifty I
mean yes and I agree with your point
that's like I like am so careful what I
say cuz I like want to be friends with
her okay so that's kind of like this
line that I walk in my life that's so
hard cuz I'm delusional and like I
really truly believe one day yes I will
be like a close Confidant of Taylor
Swift right and why do I feel like she
almost wants people around her that like
love her so much for sure for sure but
you you have to you tow that
[__] freak like I'm not going to you
know rifle through her laundry and smell
her underwear like I want her to know
like I'm cool and normal I justen to
like have this undying love and
affection and respect for you the utmost
respect the utmost respect like I've
never respected someone probably more in
my life one of my favorite things that
you do on social media cuz I also follow
you on Instagram is like post Rogue
selfies in the middle of the night with
like the most wellth thought
out thoughts on Taylor Swift's
discography like you'll point out a
certain lyric or you'll a certain era
and give your thoughts on it and it's so
beautiful it's really poignant thank you
it's actually my favorite thing to do
the reason I do that is because I do it
with my friends and whatever they think
is funny I take and put on the internet
so like I base what I should put out
like what my little bit should be based
on what my friends like right you have
like a girl gang I have a girl gang you
live with your girl gang are they your
college girl gang home friends like how
do you know the girlies and they're
always the ones filming you and giggling
in the background which makes the videos
even funnier right so there's Alice
Julia Brett Payton and Kennedy you have
five friends that's beyond impressive I
know Julia Brett and pton are from
college okay Alice was always my friend
out of college but she lived in La so we
were just always close um Kennedy is
Payton's best friend from home and moved
out to LA after college and we all just
kind of connected connected let me ask
you another question cuz I feel like
your rise in popularity and fame really
coincided with you going to Sophia
Richie's wedding which you were which
you were going to anyway I think a lot
of people were like wow he got famous
and now you have been friends with
Sophia Richie living in LA and her
family and her like in-laws so you are
at this wedding that's like the social
event of the season but you're also like
having your own moments is that weird
what was that like I just but like that
week was like fairy tale land for you or
for the wedding for the wedding it's
like I was in like a fairy tale so like
I wasn't even thinking about that really
like I thinking about yourself no Weir
when I'm at weddings I like don't weird
actually feel that like when I'm at
weddings I'm like thinking about like
love like if I ever think about myself
it's like I need a boyfriend like you
know what I mean like but by the way
with your Skyrocket to fame has that
made dating easier or harder um not
easier and not harder like it's
non-existent for usual but like I'm
going on a date tonight by the way I
feel like we have a lot of really cute
gsh Chasers well gjts HML hit my line
are you open to the DMS um so [__]
open when this all happened my dad was
like you know people are going to start
wanting to like hit your line like cuz
of like your dad did not say that no he
I think he did okay and like he was like
cuz of like everything and I'm like okay
like ew like hit my line but but
actually like but like do it not like
none none none all right well maybe you
haven't like put out that you're open
for business I'm literally so open for
business I'm about to go into forclosure
yeah he's open for business he spreads
his legs like for anyone and anything
for anyone and anything love that for
real um so now let me ask you a question
you're you're rocking out you're blowing
up who's the most famous person who
follows you on social media okay I was
actually thinking about this so Richie
doesn't count because you are friends
with her in real life yes I would
say Emma Roberts that's a good one no
that was the one where I was like you're
[__] lying yeah Emma Roberts or
Sophie Turner today's episode is brought
to you by Lululemon so Lululemon is the
One-Stop shop for this time of year
because it's swea weather so we're
wearing leggings we're looking cute
we're staying active but we're also
staying comfortable and Lululemon is
your go-to destination for anything and
everything leggings they have so many
fabulous options whatever you're looking
for whether you're super super active
and you're running and jogging or you
just want like a cute pair of leggings
to hold you in and make you look smooth
with a big chunky sweater we love a big
chunky sweater so they have a ton of
good options here are some of our
favorites the fast and free legging
which is great it's a really weightless
on body sensation it has great coverage
it's powered by their new luux fabric so
this legging is designed for those that
are looking for complete freedom when
you're running or jogging super super
active you'll feel held in you'll feel
tight they won't fall down but you'll be
able to move and have a wide range of
motion those are the fast and free
leggings also the Wonder Trin leggings
which are designed with one of
Lululemon's most Innovative Fabrics
which is everlux it's their fastest
drying fabric so if you're more of like
a sweaty queen or your crevices get a
little moist we've all been there
there's nothing to be ashamed of the
Wonder train leggings are for you they
allow you to work hard and feel dry so
you can effortly transition from sweat
to street it's great for any activities
whether you spin or are you're super
active and you're or just like a sweaty
girly like there's really nothing to be
embarrassed about my favorite pair of
leggings is the Align leggings I happen
to just love the Align collection from
Lululemon so that's always where I am
drawn to and this is like you know if
you like to wear leggings but you're not
necessarily running 26 miles in a
marathon you're just running to the
grocery store which sometimes can feel
like a marathon so those are designed by
the nulu fabric the Align leggings
they're designed for the person who
wants a lightweight low compression yoga
solution but that's also versatile
enough for casual wear so get into the
Lululemon leggings at lululemon.com
there's truly something for everyone
today's episode is also brought to you
by Legacy box think of all the time and
money your family invested in capturing
family vacations football games
birthdays your wedding whatever it may
be recording a lifetime of memories was
truly a commitment and camcorders cost
thousands of dollars tapes were
expensive and cameras of course required
film development so Legacy box exists to
preserve your family's recorded moments
digitally ensuring that they're safe
safe forever so however old you are we
personally grew up in like the VHS era
so all of our home videos from when we
were kids are were in a huge box in our
basement just Gathering dust honestly
there are so many elements that like the
heat if there's a flood it's really kind
of like dangerous to just leave your
family's memories chilling in an attic
or a basement you know leaving it up to
the elements so we ended up doing Legacy
box like a few years ago it was the best
thing ever we put all of our VHS tapes
in a box we got them back on a thumb
drive and we just literally hooked it up
to the computer and then to the TV it's
stored there forever and we just all sat
around watching like these moments of us
singing you know the Spice Girl moments
of our dad like it was really really
special so don't let another day go by
with like your VHS and old home memories
just sitting in a box Legacy box is a
simple and safe solution to digitizing
all of your memories and when you go to
legacybox.com toast you can enjoy 40%
off when you get started with Legacy box
today the process is super easy you send
in the tapes the pictures whatever you
got and their team will professionally
digitize everything by hand in the USA
and you'll get it back on the cloud or
the thumb drive uh they digitize over 15
different types of analog media and
after 10 years in B business they're the
world's largest digitizer so you ow it
to your family to safeguard your
memories don't let your photos continue
to fade become your family's hero and
save them before it's too late buy a
legacy box today at legacybox.com toast
for our exclusive off offer that's
legacybox.com
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by Thrive Cosmetics which I am
wearing today whether you're fresh faed
full Glam or somewhere in between you've
probably seen Thrive Cosmetics viral
tubing mascara probably because I'm
always talking about it and always using
it in my Tik toks so it's a turquoise
tube it's all over social media well
thrive Cosmetics beauty products are
certified 100% vegan and cruelty-free
they're made with clean skin- loving
ingredients high performance in
trademarked formulas and uncompromising
standards so it's easy to see why their
best sellers have thousands of five-star
reviews they have a ton of fabulous
products that have gone viral the liquid
lash extensions mascara what is what I
use I never used a tubing mascara before
I have very straight lashes they don't
hold a curl well and this is my everyday
go-to mascara whether I'm doing the
toast or going to an event I love it
you'll look like you have lash
extensions they also have uh
semi-permanent smoothing lipsticks which
is going to give you a visibly Fuller
smoother nourished lip with a creamy
satin finish and the one that's really
gone viral is the brilliant eye
brightener so it's a highlighter in a
stick that's made to brighten up and
open your eyes it'll give you an instant
eye lift I'm wearing it in my inner
Corner today I love an inner corner
highlight it's so Kardashian also under
your brow bone there's a million ways
you can use highlighters to make your
eyes look big and the Thrive Cosmetics
one is in a stick so you can get really
um in there and not get highlighter all
over your face and look like you've been
glitter bombed so Thrive Cosmetics is a
luxury Beauty brand that gives back it's
cause for a reason they're constantly
giving back to their community so right
now you can get an exclusive 20% off
your first order at Thrive cosmetics.com
toast that's Thrive Cosmetics
CA m t i
cs.com toast for 20% off your order
Sophie Turner we're going to talk about
Sophie Turner because Sophie Turner has
of course been in the news recently yeah
and for a multitude of reasons you know
her divorce custody Taylor Swift but why
we really need to talk about it is cuz
like she was spotted out multiple times
going to dinner with Taylor Swift
leaving Taylor Swift's apartment handing
her kids over putting them in a car all
wearing your merch yeah do you want to
know the story uh I I kind of I think I
know the story but the toaster want to
know okay so basically when all this
little stuff first happened with me the
Jonas the Jonas Brothers dueted my stuff
oh I remember with the coke with the
Coke and so like I worked with them and
when I when I worked with them Joe was
like actually you know who showed me you
was my wife was my wife and I was like
your wife Sophie and um he facetimed her
oh wow when and his I like I'm such like
a I'm such like a nosy [__] like I was
like looking at the contact name it was
like wifey oh that's like Chey yeah but
like cute cute no happy for them even
though no longer yeah oh my God in peace
yeah RP and I was like hey she was like
oh my God like da D and I was like
freaking out so when I sent the Jonas
brother's
merch um I I said I I included one for
Sophie right just like smart just to
just include one never thought she'd get
it let alone wear it to dinner with
Taylor swi
like you know what I mean like I woke up
the next day and someone texted me like
I could I could have sworn this is p
casino and I was like holy [__] that's
so crazy cuz it is puss casino and it
always will be P Casino that's so crazy
oh my God it was I like still get like
butterflies chill is thinking about it
okay I'm obsessed with that like that
and and she's out with Taylor Swift yeah
and I'm like I'm like wondering like if
Taylor got cold like would she give it
to her did Taylor ask why the [__] does
your hoodie say Pino it's really a
conversation starter if you think about
it yeah but like but then it was like
around her waist so maybe Taylor didn't
notice like I'm just like no that's a
lot for one a lot for like my brain to
like wrap around it's a lot for one
person to go through I'm sorry you had
to deal with that no like it's fine like
I like I said happy for you but also
jealous right okay so your job here
today is to join me in the past five
stories I've never been more excited for
anything now let me tell you the stories
they're not amazing okay they're not
groundbreaking but I yeah we'll make it
groundbreaking we'll make it
groundbreaking and to me like any
opportunity to steer the ation into
talking about things that I love Taylor
Swift yes that's fabulous so Jake I have
a question for you okay are you ready
for the past five stories I'm so [__]
ready for the past five stories let's
[__] go first story of course we have
to talk about Taylor and for those who
are like stop talking about Taylor no
and there's only one story so just calm
down um the ratings are in at the Chiefs
Jets game oh okay so they have hit a a
new high for the regular season 27
million people tuned into that game on
Sunday making her uh second week
cheering on Travis Kelsey so The Game
featuring the Kansas City Chiefs versus
the New York Jets averaged approximately
27 million viewers making it the most
watched Sunday show since the Super Bowl
on Fox in February the power of [__]
swifties it's so crazy I will say it
also like I don't know how Sports
ratings work because I watched I'm
trying to get into football like for
Taylor so last night I watched another
football game oh it was so boring oh my
god there was like nobody famous on the
team and one team was so much better
than the other that like it wasn't even
like a competition yeah it's like why am
watching and everyone was like kind of
being bad at their jobs like catch the
ball like it's not I was confused so
compared to the I went to the game on
Sunday and it was actually so
interesting like there was so many
different celeb players of course like
Travis but then the whole Aaron Rogers
there was a lot of celebrity energy and
both teams were playing so good till the
very end we were like who's going to win
who's going to lose so maybe that would
have made the ratings High anyway then
it's Taylor it's Taylor it's [__]
Taylor I walked into well Brett always
watches football but I walked in to
Brett watching it and I was like what
what are you doing she's like well I'm
watching for Taylor yeah of course and
I'm like honestly yeah yeah what are
your thoughts now that NFL is getting
like a little bit criticized for how
they're interacting with this whole
Taylor Swift Saga on social media like
changing their bio making like their
Twitter Banner pictures of Taylor making
a lot of Tik toks the MC's during the
games like what are your thoughts on
like are they going too far I think it's
a it's like a little much I think like
what the [__] are they supposed to do
like everyone's talking about it if they
unchartered territory it's Uncharted
Territory and if they didn't do it
everyone would be like oh my God the NFL
should have lent into the swifties more
yeah you know what I mean they should be
leading in but I do think they're taking
it like a tad far like I think they're
forgetting that they're the NFL like a
major billion doll Media Company who is
successful with and without Taylor and I
love that they are getting involved but
now it just feels like a little much it
does but why do I kind of love that
they're forgetting that the NFL because
of Taylor Swift me too and I love that
like they're kind of bending the knee
and like acting like [__] loser for
like a girl yeah I love it and I love
how angry boys are getting about it oh
my God so last night at the Giants game
they played I think during like a time
out there was a commercial or something
on the screens that included Taylor
Swift and the entire Stadium started to
boo shut the [__] up and the Giants lost
by 30 points and so when when you're
toxic and negative like you get out what
you put in that is disgusting it's
disgusting it makes me so mad like first
of all we're only talking about your
losery ass team because of Taylor first
of all you're welcome second of all your
team sucks why don't you focus on that
[__] first of all and second of all if
you watch Miss Americana which the
entire country has you know that at the
2009 VMAs she thought everyone was
booing her so that's incredibly
triggering also like I just don't I
don't I don't get it what do you not oh
you're going to pretend like Blank Space
doesn't [__] slap no I'm so sick
honestly of people pretending like all
this hobl for Taylor is not warranted it
is so godamn warranted honestly I think
we should be doing more we should be
doing more and she deser like people
forget like people are like sitting here
acting like Taylor Swift like she she
has been at this since she was 12 years
old lest we forget lest we forget like
20 years like she was meeting every
single fan [__] writing every single
song she has she has worked her [__]
ass off for this moment right here like
let her have it let her have it and I
just like this whole philosophy and I
think it's mostly by like men who are
very dismissive of Taylor Swift as an
artist a person and also like the
culture and the fandom around her being
like Oh you're crazy or like you're just
obsessed with her she's just blonde and
tall like it they minimize it and it
really actually bothers me because I I
can speak from my own personal
experience and I think a lot of swifties
can like just the Testament to like her
work it's so powerful it's so good she
does it all herself like they just act
like it's like f they're very flippant
about it and it's like you know teenage
girls shaking for no reason like [__]
[__] off well teenage girlss Shak for
the Beatles too right and Elvis yeah
like do you think Elvis is overhyped no
because he's a boy David do you think
the Beatles were just too a little
little too overhyped hon in the moment
they probably would have for sure
they're dumb and they undermine think I
saw like Tink say this once like people
undermine like female Joy they do and I
think also like the um even I feel like
I remember this with One Direction all
there was so much hype and like so many
young girls like screaming and you just
minimize like young girls and Taylor
Swift fans are now of all all ages but
they started out as young girls cuz they
were girls who were her age and things
that like young girls like enjoy get
minimized and diminish and thought of as
stupid when at the end of the day like
those young girls are like they're going
to grow up and be adults and they're
going to enjoy the same things that they
enjoy so shut up yeah shut up and you
know what I think like a lot of the way
people act at football is really [__]
unreasonable getting you're getting
arrested at a football game like get
therapy you're really no you're starting
fights I saw literally this woman
beating up another person just from
another team why because they like
disagreed right like it's like St
Twitter
getting you think we're crazy like I you
literally bet you put your [__]
family finances into for you put your
house in foreclosure you lose your
child's tuition because you're betting
on [__] a game you're putting
together fantasy leagues like I could go
off about NFL but I don't because I
understand people have their [__]
interest I understand that so get a
[__] grip Chad oh my God yes me
spitting not no you just spat
oh my God no but agreed and also like
people forget that like like people
forget how much music Taylor Swift has
to her name like people forget
everything everyone just forgets
everything the second like Taylor Swift
enters she just people forget everything
they forget everything they forget the
amazing work that she did like when she
was leaving her music label and she was
going to find another label she got
herself the best possible deal but she
would only go to the specific label that
would give her terms to all of the
artists on their roster at the time so
huge artists like Nicki Minaj huge
artists who are just happen to be at the
label that she chose are getting better
streaming deals and getting better
Revenue shares because she's not a
selfless a selfish person like she
justes she's so charitable and she's not
annoying about it the way that other
people are like I'm just really tired of
having to explain myself wait same like
I'm tired of saying the same thing ever
which is that she's the biggest
superstar in the world and she's also
like somewhat she's relatable no and
let's like stop pretending like it's
this like mysterious anomaly why she is
the biggest star in the world like she's
incredibly talented nobody questioned
The Beatles nobody so like stop
also this is just like my favorite thing
about her and like people like the like
I don't just love her cuz she makes a
[__] Banger I love her because I've
never seen someone be so confident in
their own creativity and like exert it
with such like confidence and power it
like makes me want to like be creative
in my own right and like she is such a
hard worker and then she like treats all
those around her well like the [__]
bonuses she gave to those drivers that
drive her [__] tour like dancers tour
I'm like did you see that [__] like
talk show clip that resurfaced where
they were like I mean you know backup
singers don't have health insurance and
she was like well mine do yep like
obsessed obsessed obsessed she's here
for a reason and I'm done defending it
no I'm done and I like how we're like
defending ourselves and nobody's coming
at us right now we're just preparing
we're preparing because this is the life
of a true Swifty it is the life of a
true Swifty like I remember in college
people would be like what like oh my God
you guys are like sick for her and now
you are I I love to see people eating
their words yeah and now you are and and
now we've said it yeah and now we've
said it all right are you ready for our
next story which is not about Taylor but
it kind of is I'm sure we'll find a way
to drawback so Beyonce's in final talks
to release her Renaissance concert film
in a similar deal to Taylor Swift
through AMC Theaters following Taylor
Swift's deal with them so a film based
on Beyonce's Smash Hit Renaissance World
Tour is in advanced talks to distribute
directly with AMC Theaters sources with
knowledge of the project told variety so
CIAA held preliminary talks with major
Studios and streamers two weeks ago
urging the players to be ready to bid on
the project that the has been developing
for years one that not only includes the
top grossing 2023 live show of the
Renaissance tour but um parts of what
people have been waiting for the Visual
Album for Renaissance I'm so excited and
a documentary style account of the
making of the record and building out
the tour I'm sure Blue Ivy Cameo will be
like a big part of that I'm very excited
they're saying it'll come out December
1st um the Renaissance World Tour is
expected to gross close to $560 million
in ticket
sales and um the Beyonce deal is
following on the heels of the Taylor
Swift one
which is hers is more of a
straightforward concert film based on
the the Eros tour whereas Beyonce is
more like a a conglomerate of things
[__] hyp for that a Visual Album um
the terms for Taylor's diff are deal are
known to be incredibly favorable she
self- financed her project and she'll
take home more than half of the ticket
receipts Beyonce will receive the same
Arrangement stands to pocket more than
50% of the worldwide grossing an Insider
added the industry is trafficking Taylor
Swift's AMC experiment to open up north
of $100 million in October do you have
tickets um yeah I have tickets when did
you get tickets for Friday okay so I got
tickets for Friday night me too Friday
night and I didn't get like amazing
seats uhuh so I also bought Saturday at
noon and when when everyone was buying
tickets on Friday night I was like the
thing was panicking and and freezing and
[__] refreshing so I just went to
Saturday and it was completely open and
I kind of like love a Saturday Mata I
love a Saturday mat and then I just got
invited to a party on Friday night so I
think I'm not going to go to my Friday
night so if anybody wants my tickets
like just DM me I'll send them to you
you can have them for free like I I
don't want bad seats right you know can
I just say I love this era of concert
films in theaters it does feel like
we're moving backwards like where were
you when the One Direction concert movie
came out cuz my ass was in the theater
really yeah I just remember like Justin
Bieber Never Say Never in theater course
I saw I think I believe I saw Katy Perry
Part of Me in theaters as well I've
never seen that okay so one of the
running jokes here on the toast is that
like there's four celebrity
documentaries that I talk about
endlessly and Katy Perry's part of me is
one of them it's one of the best ones
celebrity documentaries got to a point
where we we don't need to hear from you
all the time all the time no offense
Shawn Mendes Wonder like that was a
documentary yeah it was on Netflix it
was called Wonder was like part
documentary part concert and like it was
bad and we just didn't need it people
got a little too comfortable sharing
with us honestly we're okay and there
are a few examples of the bad ones and
Katy Parry is an example of the good one
so is Gaga 5 foot2 you know I've never
seen that in fall and I'm like the
biggest Gaga fan and I've never seen it
in Fall it's one of the she's preparing
for the Super Bowl it's so good I like a
documentary that's like different like
focusing on one specific I feel like
every celebrity documentary like gives
us like [__] we don't need like I like
how Gaga's focused on like a twoe period
where she's getting ready for what is
probably the biggest concert of her life
like I like the specificity of it and
you know who makes a great documentary
who Beyonce she does I loved homecoming
loved homecoming life is but a dream
which is the HBO one where she sing
dream she's singing in the back of the
cart and she sings yellow with Jay-Z yes
but she oh on the boat yeah but when
she's singing listen from dream girls
practicing I think she was about to
perform it on like Oprah or something
that's one of the like when I get drunk
and sit around with my friends on YouTu
YouTube and we like watch dumb videos
I'm like we need to watch that one I
also do the first time Fifth Harmony
ever sang together when they were when
they were a band called list at Simon
cow's house and Mark Anthony is like so
blown away by camil Cab's vocals there's
like a few YouTube videos that like give
me chills oo I have like a few go-tos
like that what are they like well
similar um you know when Beyonce sings
Halo acoustic and she's like on the
drums yes that's one another one is oh
another one is 1989 tour when Taylor
Swift brought out Mary J blig to sing
you said I never be leader yeah so good
and I well aside from YouTube videos my
go-to is Miss Marana so good just cuz
like I like I quote it it's easy I fall
asleep to it whatever but like as far as
like YouTube video goes I honestly watch
a lot of like vine compilations I love
that a lot of people don't know the 1989
World Tour which was released
exclusively on Apple music and then like
scrubbed from the internet forever is on
YouTube I watch it every time I get
drunk um of all the movies Taylor has
put out like 1989 we had reputation we
have Miss Americana what is your
favorite work of work of uh film film
work that Taylor's released Miss Marana
Miss Marana just because like I'm pretty
sure she did there's this moment in Miss
Americana where she where it's like it's
showing her it's I love how it just
shows her rise so it's like showing how
the crowd changes and she's like I had
everything I ever wanted and she's like
standing proud and tall and you just
like and it's the entire crowd for 19 9
and it's just like oh my God like I know
it's kind of a puff piece like I know
it's kind of like obviously she had
creative control but can I tell you my
favorite moment in Miss Americana yeah
she's driving a Toyota I know a little
unrealistic honestly like I'm not buying
it when she goes to her mom's house yeah
but I also love when she's going to her
mom house cuz you kind of see the real
her she's like standing like this
watching TV and she's like I I'm like I
like will live and die for like if
Andrea Swift has one fan it's me if
Andrea Swift has zero fans I'm dead no
dad I love her I [__] love that whole
family me too I don't really feel like I
know Austin at all yeah okay not as like
veering away from the story you were
saying how like it's crazy how
everyone's going now like doing ticketed
theaters instead of streamers I prefer
the ticketed theaters because okay well
I remember do you think it has to do
with the strike or it's because they're
getting more money no I think it's cuz
they're getting more money and I think
it's cuz like they're realizing I think
like after I honestly think after the
pandemic they were like wait people like
the theaters oh my God I thought people
like streaming and we missed it yeah
everyone missed it so now everyone's
going back to theaters and Billy iish
did a concert film on Apple TV right no
yes but she also did like the happier
than ever tour in theaters oh and her
fans were like there's like these viral
videos of like her fans like screaming
and jumping up and down like in the
theater which is obviously going to be
Taylor with and Beyonce fans yeah I feel
like it's going to be a little Annoying
to be at the Aros tour I'm scared no I
like I want to sit back and enjoy it
like maybe I'll you can like
hum standing up dancing I mean there's
going to be a lot like honestly I find
it really
annoying I just want to enjoy right like
we're not at a concert we're in a
civilized theater you know what I'm so
excited for to see in high quality the
[__] opening I know chills lover do
you ever go back and just watch your
videos from the ARs Tour on your phone I
barely took videos good for you I barely
took videos which shows did you go to I
went to Vegas Vegas and then I went
three nights in a row in La nice and I
got the [__] sickest surprise songs
uh no I did no what did did what did you
[__] get again I was so angry when I was
in Nashville I got talk about jealousy I
talk about 15 I got 15 no and Abigail
was in the crowd and Abigail was in the
crowd and she like changed the lyrics
and then I got what was the second one
it was um it was 1989 oh Out of the
Woods that's not fair and then in New
York I got getaway
car that by the way and then in the
second night I got Holy Ground yeah and
then one I think I peed during it I
think it might have been I think it
might have been false god I think it was
false god yeah what did you get I got
okay so my first one I got our song
which was like cute cute cute cute I
want maroon everyone knows like I want
[__] maroon and then the second one
was like snow on the beach cute cute
cute it was good she was like talking
about Lana which was exciting but L
wasn't there yeah and I was like okay
and then what about la la okay if I'm
remembering correctly the first night I
got dressed it's good it no it was I'm
not even the biggest dress stand but she
didn't I love it when she doesn't
introduce it she just goes our sacred
moments yeah no because when she doesn't
introduce it it's because there's so
much to be said yeah Carly Carly Right
Carly was there on night three oh yeah
that was crazy stands in the stands in
the stands and then apparently she got
moved I don't know we'll talk about what
happened at my show Kate Upton was
sitting right behind me and I'm like
what are you doing here girl like get
down there get down there and did she
move and then Molly Ringwald we were
right in front of the um the celebrity
tent I was just watching everybody come
in and out Molly ring weld appeared to
be on the phone with Kate Upton and like
had her escorted down okay not Molly
ringal saving the day saving STD STD STD
saving the day saving the day but I got
dress I'm trying to remember I Got King
of my heart which was [__] insane
that's really hard for me yeah it was
[__] insane what else did I get oh
and then I got new Romantics and New
Year's Day new Romantics yeah which was
it I mean it was [__] amazing what
show got ever more all my waves of being
CR is there a line that we can just
across and when I was sh
I
thought so good like that was the last
oh I got
Exile which was good that's good yeah it
was like sick and like the crowd was
singing the crowd was like singing her
part back to her it was like [__]
sick in no like the aerosur was the best
nights of my life of my like that was
like I was like my Coachella I'm like
night three like got to go yeah
literally Coachella yeah it was
Coachella and like also 1989 T version
coming out on my birthday not to be like
pitting women against women but whose
movie do you think will will make more
money Beyonce or Taylor it's really hard
to know I don't know I don't know
because their tours are so neck and neck
but you know that they both like
basically save the economy I know I do
think it'll be more about like behaviors
in like Taylor Swifts fans are like
who's more likely to go to the theater
Taylor fans or Beyonce fans I think both
of them I think both of them they they
honestly if I have to name the two most
loyal and dedicated fan Bas it's the
Beehive and the swifties and the
toasters and the toaster yes today's
episode is brought to you by the inky
list skincare can be confusing and with
all of the complicated Beauty jargon it
can seem nearly impossible to figure out
what is actually best for your skin now
you don't need to figure it out on your
own because you can shop with confidence
with the inky list an award-winning
science-backed skincare brand that has
the right ingredients at an affordable
price to get the results you're looking
for whether it's targeting acne reducing
Fine Lines boosting hydration the inky
list creates a unique skincare routine
that really works so you can reach your
skin goals if you don't know where to
start your first stop should be their
online skincare quiz that'll answer any
of your questions so you can make better
decisions about your skin skin like do I
really need a toner what is polyglutamic
acid or is skipping moisturizer making
my oily skin worse you can get a whole
new skincare routine for under $30 and
if you already know what you need you
can find products with ingredients that
work like retinol and vitamin C without
breaking the bank plus the inky list
just launched a new product that will
take your routine to the next level
their new Plumping lip balm you can get
40% plumper lips in Just 4 weeks without
filler just Fuller check out uh the
before and afters on their website if
you don't believe them iny lless I feel
like skincare can be really intimidating
so just going to a website that's going
to do it all for you is fabulous so
right now the inky lus is offering our
listeners uh 20% off their purchase with
promo code toast go to the inky list
spelled i n ke Y and use promo code
toast for 20% off your order that's the
inky list I ke y list.com that promo
code is toast today's episode is also
brought to you by game time you
shouldn't have to worry about when
you're buying tickets for your next big
event game time is the fast and easy way
to buy tickets for all the sports music
comedy and Theater events near you with
killer last minute deals Allin prices
views from your seat and their best
price guante game time takes the guest
workk at of buying tickets so game time
is the only ticketing app that gives you
complete peace of mind with your
purchase you could see the view from
your seat before you buy so you know
exactly what you're getting into no
surprises I love that you also get
all-in pricing so your total is being
given to you UPF front so you know
you're getting a great deal without
hidden fees what's worse than that like
you're shopping on a ticketing website
and you find a good price and by the
time you go to check out it's double
because there were all these faka fees
not with game time they're showing you
everything all up front and you can buy
uh tickets within seconds they're
obsessed with finding you ways to save
money so they have deals on tickets
right up to the day of the event even up
to an hour before it starts it's a great
place to find last minute seats you can
find exclusive Flash Deals and sponsored
deals on tickets for football basketball
baseball concerts comedy theater and
more with Zone deals you pick the
section and Game Time picks the seats
and the best part part is the game part
the best part is the game time guad and
T which means you'll always get the best
price so if you find tickets in the same
section in row Elsewhere for Less game
time will credit you 110% of the
difference so take the guess workk out
of buying tickets with game time because
enjoying concerts or theater or Sports
should not be torturous but but these
days it is download the game time app
create an account use code toast and
you'll get $20 off your first purchase
terms apply again create an account and
redeem code toast t o a s for $20 off
download game time today last minute
tickets lowest price Guan our next story
I'm so [__] obsessed with like I
could vomit Kim catrell is stripping
down in shapewear for a new campaign for
skims so and there a new campaign every
week for it's so true but you know what
if they keep slaying the talent
Department like I'm okay with it it
doesn't feel repetitive and it doesn't
feel annoying yet yeah they had ice that
was cool they just get such good people
when they got the two girls from um
White Lotus so quickly after white L SCH
up they do a really good job so the Sex
in the City Star who's 67 stripped down
for Kim Kardashian's latest shapeware
campaign striking a pose in some of the
labels most loved Styles so like who
cares about the skims I'm just like
upset obessed with this partnership I'm
obsessed with Kim catrell like getting
her flowers yeah oh should I feel like
so in defense of Kim catrell at all
times because when it comes to the
reboot like I know if everybody's mad at
you like you're usually the problem but
I don't know I feel like Kim Katrell was
wronged I feel like so wronged I don't
know I don't know I don't have any
Insider information and I don't have any
proof I just really feel like Kim
catrell like I could see a world in
which Sarah Jessica Parker like was a
[__] um yeah and I can see I mean
like it's like Kim Katrell like from
what I've SE I haven't like I'm not like
the most dedicated Sex in the City
Watcher but like what she was the
funniest one she like the thing is I
think the show was like Sarah Jessica
Parker show and Kim Katrell got like a
role and she made the most of it and I
think for many people she was the best
character she was Far Away the best
actress she had like the most
interesting story lines and honestly
like in this modern age she's kind of
like the most modern woman you know she
was a business owner she was very
sexually free very um gender fluid
almost when it came to her Partners like
she was that [__] and she made the most
out of her role and I think like there
definitely became competition when it
was supposed to be Carri show and if you
watch a show like car's the [__]
worst like we hate Carrie she's a
terrible friend a terrible business
person like not even a good writer cover
me and Kim Katrell like was that [__]
Samantha is the best part of the show
there's no question about it so I think
like the Dynamics on set were probably
really toxic and I'm sure you know
everybody's truth is their own right but
I I stand with Kim Katrell I always
stand with Kim Katrell she's everything
and you know Patricia field who like is
responsible for all the styling on the
original show and like the iconic looks
she left with Kim Katrell oh then that
says the most I know it's the thing is I
go where Pat goes they call her Pat uhuh
I I stand with Pat well did you see I
mean obviously you probably saw Kim's um
Cameo it was the most we need to
convince people we don't have beef so
let me pay you a bag to like film a
scene completely separate from me on the
other side of on the other side of the
country yeah and I watched her on The
View talking about it and she was like I
said you know I didn't want to do it and
you know they offered me and I was like
you know what sure but I'm only doing it
if Pat comes back for this episode
[__] loyalty so like the thing is
there's more to this story and I'm just
not going to let it brush under like Kim
control watered more money Kim control
was jealous I think there's more so
people like skims platforming Kim
catrell I am here for because I think
she was done dirty I really do I also
think so and let me not forget she plays
the iconic role of Britney Spears's
mother in the movie Crossroads like
she's an enormous Talent she is so
wildly talented she's funny she's a good
actress I have always [__] loved Kim
control and I haven't ever really been
the biggest Sex in the City fan that's
so interesting I feel like like it like
you're from New York right I know but
I'm like liking like when I like watch
TV I'm like liking like alien
documentaries and like sci-fi stuff
really yeah I know I'm like what are you
watching right now like okay I'm
watching this show called encounters
which is really bad okay it's really
really bad I appreciate the honesty and
it's like I'm like if I'm watching a
show about aliens like convince me
convince me that you want to be
convinced I understand that cuz I'm not
convinced you're not convinced no but
I'm also watching the show called
Invasion also about aliens oh you need
help I need so much help you the best
laugh like it kind of scares me I see it
coming and it's so loud I'm like
obsessed with it that's like my real
hardcore laugh no I'm so honored you've
done it like four times yeah cuz you're
[__] hysterical I love you I love you
I love
you but I'm watching Invasion what else
am I watching I'm watching well it's off
the air right now but Yellow Jackets oh
I feel that's like very uh disturbing it
is so disturbing it is so good really
like talk about like actors being like
pushed to their limits oh I love that
yeah like you know what I mean like [__]
like they had to like prepare for this
episode where like she gave birth in the
woods I love like sorry spoiler alert
but like whatever who gives birth no
kidding like I honestly forget the name
but I'm watching Yellow Jackets what
else am I watching um Invasion Yellow
Jack you want to act is that like one of
your goals yes okay you want to do like
an
improv okay okay like with you yeah know
when I was at camp we had like in the
was like the like the drama crew like
they would put on a play and like so
every now and then we'd have to do like
drama exercises okay so one of the
exercises is you guys are going to give
us you're going to give us a location
like tell us where we are like a coffee
shop a restaurant something like that
and you're going to give us
a
word you're at aan we're at aan okay say
that again the bill the
bill okay can you believe dinner last
night that like nobody offered to pay
the bill except for me well yes I
actually can believe it because we were
at a grocery store right right but like
I understand because you know it's it's
so interesting almost because it's like
a grocery store but dinner Allin one
which I guess hasn't been done before no
I'm like a really thin person and I feel
like arowana is for thin people and I
just go in there and I feel really like
excited to be around other thin people
100% it's also like I could eat the mac
and cheese and feel like it's good for
me you want to know an actually fun fact
about me yes I've never been to Aran
ever ever it's really not for me like
uhhuh it's like a healthy grocery store
but like I get I am like very like I get
the same thing every single time we're
not even acting no I don't we're not
even acting cuz we're so authentic we're
so authentic we're method acting what do
you get from Aran okay you're going to
be like ew it's actually not bad add the
keto pork stir fry no I understand I'm
not KET first of all no it's not keto
it's just like spicy pork okay and then
I get a side of white rice okay I'm kind
of a rice afficionado like rice roast
rice is my number one favorite food and
I'm very particular about what types of
rice like rice peel off no thank you I
don't need peas in my rice you don't
like rice pea no what kind of rice like
rate the rice at Aran they only have one
oh actually no they have multiple rice
they have cilantro rice I I'll live with
it but I'll pick around the cilantro oh
it's not my fave and then they have
Jasmine rice and then they have um fried
rice so I would actually go jasmine rice
fried rice cilantro rice okay you know
fun fact before I started past that puss
it was orally going to be a rice review
account okay I would have subscribed I
would have been your first follower I
love rice you want to know what my
latest obsession with rice is yeah rice
with truffle oil and soy sauce okay
first of all rice with soy sauce like at
a sushi restaurant like I grew up in the
city and like theol the cool thing to do
was like go get sushi and like I don't
like sushi so I was right I was it was
more like Haru cuz I was an uptown love
Haru love Haru I would always order just
like a bowl of white rice at a mommy and
like douse my rice and soy sauce it's
literally like a a delicacy it's a dely
you have to put the right amount of soy
sauce on yeah if you overdo it it could
start to taste like um soup like alcohol
yeah alcohol soy sauce soup yeah it's
like too much it's too much I also a
teriyaki sauce on your
rice [__] you need to try the truffle
oil and soy sauce okay well here's the
thing I'm coming to LA in like two weeks
um and I think that you you should take
me to Aran wait holy [__]
okay you heard it here first I'm not
letting you bail on this this is
happening no no we're going maybe I'll
Vlog it for our patreon like I I need to
try like a smoothie right yeah but like
I don't like like juice like can I be
honest yeah okay so I once okay you know
when you like throw up from something
but it's not because of it it's just
like you throw it when you threw it up
yeah the Trel pizza from seraphine I
threw it up um on the side on the side
of mon Highway and and Ben always orders
it it's called the pizza De Sophia it's
like a truffle like pizza with the white
stuff in the middle what when I smell it
I'm on that's kind of rude of him to do
that no I'm on Route 27 dry heing out of
a cab wait that's like mean of him to do
that I know he like doesn't care either
that's rude because it's so traumatizing
I threw up I got back from a trip and I
got airwan and I got the haly Bieber
smoothie just cuz I was like [__]
thirsty and or whatever they're they're
calling it now strawberry glaze and I
got it and it was good but then I also
got the tuna I'm going to PUK the tuna
sandwich the tuna sandwich or the SP the
not the tuna sandwich the Sushi sandwich
cuz I was like I want to smooth and I
want the [__] Sushi sandwich um later
that night I obviously threw up for 5
hours yeah of course and I threw up the
smoothie and the tuna sandwich so I can
no longer eat smoothies or eat sushi
from Maran or have smoothies the only
smoothie I can have is the peanut butter
blast the only smoothie I can have is a
milkshake and I love milkshakes so much
I [__] love milkshakes I can only
have smoothies when they taste like
milkshakes have you ever had Sonic never
I've been desperate to go okay so I had
never had it but we filmed a mukbang and
we were like going to places and there
was a Sonic I'm like let's go to Sonic
what if we just went to Sonic
and I didn't really know much about the
menu there but it's really like a drinks
place they have a ton of stuff but
they're known for they do like crazy
collab drinks like Dr Pepper slushy they
have milkshakes they have regular shakes
so we got um like an Oreo milkshake a
Reese's smoothie it was so [__] good
we also got a soft pretzel it was the
best thing I ever had I love soft
pretzels Sonic and it was such a clean
like I had been to like four fast food
restaurants day like just cuz we were
doing mukbang this one was so Jackie was
pregnant so like I was one to like run
in and she was locked in the car and
like I would run in get the food it was
so annoying wait I thought they brought
it to on roller skates not in the city
they have Sonics here it was in Queens I
don't know if there's one in the in like
the burough of Manhattan but um I think
when you go to a Sonic in like a proper
neighborhood yeah they'll roll it out to
you so let's go in La let's go in La
will you drive me I don't I don't like I
don't drive you don't we were talking
about that Jackie doesn't drive either I
can't I'll crash Why where did you grow
up New York in the suburbs no in
Washington Heights okay so you wouldn't
drive in Washington Heights yeah my dad
drove me to school every day okay and I
just can't drive like my dad's like the
most stereotypical like Jewish dad like
he's like scared like of me like leaving
the house so like I guess it's like
stereotypical Jewish mom but like it's
same thing and he is like scared of like
me to like experience the world and so
it honestly makes my life easier because
I don't have to [__] learn how to
drive and you have like pay for parking
car yeah pay for parking like I'll just
Uber okay I mean I I drive now I I I
don't really need to I never drive
because I'm in the city Ben drives me
around but imagine living in La it's
like a little debilitating it is but
like I'm always with my friends and they
all Drive oh that's true that's what's
so nice about having roommates yeah
roommates and friends like I that's what
I'm saying like I have five friends each
one of those five friends drives okay
and so we're going to Aran when I'm in
La yeah okay do they have chicken
fingers they do they're not my fav well
they're not like chicken fingers they're
like healthy they're like like the the
it's
like I don't know it's like it's I don't
know it's not my fav some people love
them some people love them you know
what's really good there is the
glutenfree mac and cheese why got to be
gluten-free I don't know but it doesn't
taste it do you have mac and cheese
period regular no it's only Gluten-Free
mac and cheese like that's so aroan and
that's why it's not for me I know but
it's so good like you'll go and be like
okay a great question great like
thought-provoking conversation yeah it
was honestly so easy cuz we didn't even
act we just like started talking and and
scene good work everybody all right are
you ready for our next story I am uh
Pema Anderson has got a makeup free at
Paris fashion week and jam Lee Curtis is
losing her goddamn mind about it
so Jamie Le Curtis loses her mind over
anything and everything no it's so true
she kind of needs a
realin
sorry oh my God I'm dying I love your
laugh okay Pamela Anderson is leaving
her Mark at least that's the sentiment
Jam Lee Curtis recently shared so it
really was pretty fabulous that Pamela
Anderson went to like a big time Fashion
Week event and did not wear a single
stitch of makeup Jamie Le Curtis posted
a photo of Pamela without the makeup and
she goes like this in all caps the
natural beauty revolution has officially
begun
Pamela Anderson in the middle of Fashion
Week with so many pressures and postures
and this woman showed up and claimed her
seat at the table with nothing on her
face I am so impressed and floored by
this act of courage and
Rebellion now let me say something I
love to see a woman supporting another
woman right but to make such a big deal
out of someone not wearing makeup and
calling it courageous and rebellious
like yeah it's giving do you know that
commercial of Jennifer Aniston and the
kid who has cancer and he's like my mom
says I'm the most beautiful boy in the
world she goes I love your confidence
like that's what that's given you know
like to remark so hugely and use such
big words like courage and courageous
and Rebellion like you making it such a
big deal is is making it's really not
courageous to wear makeup to not wear
makeup it shouldn't be it shouldn't be
and Pamela Anderson did it and she did
it like she looked Fab she looks [__]
fabulous I will say while Jam Lee
curtis' sentiment it makes me giggle I
agree with it like it's like awesome and
like I [__] love that Pamela Anderson
who was like this huge bombshell in the
9s or ' 80s or whatever
like like the 30s yeah like whenever is
now coming out and it's like you want me
back you want me to be this [__]
bombshell I'm going to come back on my
own terms I think it's so cool I think
it's so cool too I'm rewatching The
Nanny uhuh which is one of the great
joys of my life and I cannot recommend
it enough like it's the best sitcom and
the amount of celebrity cameos they have
on there is so crazy so I was watching
last night Selen di was on episode the
one I watched last night had Roseanne
Bar Seline Dion Elizabeth Taylor was on
an episode crazy cameos and Pamela
Anderson uh she's kind of like a
recurring character she comes on on
three different episodes like in three
different seasons she plays Heather
biblo the woman um FR fiance left her
for okay and she's so amazing and I
really forget cuz that was like a little
bit before my time and I didn't watch
like bayat growing up it really it was
the 80s I really forget her impact and I
think that's why her documentary that
came that's a good documentary that's a
[__] sick documentary that I think
that's why it was so powerful cuz like
there's a whole generation of people us
included like who didn't grow up with
Pamela Anderson and didn't really
understand like her impact on like the
beauty standard and what she went
through in the sex tape I watched Pam
and Tommy the Hulu show it was amazing
and it was really upsetting okay I need
to watch the whole thing happened Pamela
was like pregnant she experienced a
miscarriage because she was so stressed
out people were extorting her for money
her documentary ended up making like
millions and Milli I mean not her
documentary her sex tape ended up making
like millions and she didn't see a scent
not a scent because penth house like
bought it illegally so [__] up it so
[__] up and she went through all of
that and like we know the stories of the
girls of Our Generation like Kim and
Paris but we don't know like really she
like Pam Anderson was a Trailblazer and
like she went through it and nobody was
on her side at the time right cuz people
were like e even the show that I watched
Pam and tommmy was made without her
consent and she was very vocal in not
wanting wanted people not to watch it
even though I do think it made her look
really good and sympathetic she I think
she wanted people to hear it on the
Netflix documentary which was really
popular totally get that by the way
that's like a business woman thinking
yeah and so now she here here she's
again like doing the most for women
wearing no makeup to parach Meek and
really looking stunning yeah she looks
gorgeous she's just such a natural
beauty too yeah she really is and she's
like such a mom it's so it's so crazy
like she's said so many eras of her life
and then like I love when things in pop
culture don't make sense and one of the
things that like makes no sense to me is
like or just like that connects is like
her son was a cast member on the Hills
New Beginnings reality show yeah she was
on it Brandon and he was one of the ones
one of her sons who was like one of the
filmmakers on the documentary oh yeah so
it's just like a in Inner Circle
Hollywood thing that I love yeah I Lov
that love that all right are you ready
for a fifth and final story I am it's
about one of my favorite things in the
world and I'm curious what your thoughts
are do you play pickle ball I don't and
I was literally just saying the other
day I don't [__] get it okay but have
you played no that's why you don't get
it okay can you explain please cuz I
really don't like everyone's treating
pickle ball like first of all did it
just get invented no but it's recently
popularized okay it's like everyone's
like pickle ball pickle ball pickle ball
pickle ball I'm like I don't pickle what
the thing is for me at least like I love
things that are active that don't
require me to like run a lot like I'm
that why people like pickle ball so it's
it's like a fabulous workout and it's a
really fun game because it's basically
all the fun of tennis without the
running the court is I would say a third
of the size of a tennis sore oh yeah
okay so I could get involved and you
play on a team of two so there's really
like no running involved and you can do
like sick like trick shots like once you
learn to play it's like really fun but
apparently pickle pickle ball is
wreaking havoc across the United States
so the game's rapid rise had made has
made for ugly turf wars Furious noise
noise complaints violence lawsuits and
even potential criminal charges how so
Chuck line the city manager in Glendale
Colorado has said I have had to go over
to our Recreational Sports Center and
tell 70-year-old men if you threaten to
hit our Sports Center Director in the M
with the paddle again I'm going to kick
you out this guy never anticipated that
his job might include lecturing senior
citizens about how to play nicely but
nothing has been off limits since the
pickers began showing up in Earnest in
the Denver en is that what they're
called though yep a couple months ago a
group of fierce competitors all over the
age of 60 refused to leave the city's
outdoor tennis courts when they were
asked by maintenance staff because the
SCS were the courts were scheduled to be
resurfaced the player stood there ground
yelled you can't make us until the cops
finally showed up also there's a big
problem with pickle ball noise
complaints how so the ball it's like a
wole ball with the holes in it and when
you hit it against your paddle it makes
a really annoying popping sound and it's
a small court so it'll goes pop pop pop
pop pop it's like it's actually really
annoying it's like loud too when I play
in New York I play in the middle of
Central Park so like it doesn't bother
anyone right but CH people are like yeah
so and they they've converted 30% of
pickle ball courts in the united 30% of
tennis courts in the United States to
pickle ball courts so it's literally now
there's like beef with the tennis a lot
of professional tennis players have been
like um arguing like build your own
courts don't use ours like there's a lot
of drama can I say something I think
yeah I think that piece is a hit piece
by the tennis community hot take I you
know what I could see it but the thing
is people love and they're not stopping
like this summer there's I think 15
courts in the middle of Central Park
good luck getting a time slot like it's
so [__] popular that the people who
own it they they just opened a indoor
one in Long Island City for the winter
like it's so popular it's only getting
more popular so like people like the
tennis people like need to get a grip
okay so you know what we're going to do
in LA when we go to aan we're also going
to play Pickleball together where do you
play in LA I don't know like that I
trust you oh I'll find out I trust you
well so the one here it's a chain
they're all over the East Coast Co Coast
called City pickle maybe they have La
location CP not
SP CP it's been a long day it's been
yeah long yeah I would love to play it's
so much fun and if you're not athletic
are you athletic I feel like you're
always working out on your Instagram at
recently started my workout Journey me
too and I'm like loving it I'm loving it
too okay so when you first started
working out were you like crippled by
soreness yeah and never moved to like I
but I would like tell everyone I was
sore like that was like my like I wanted
to be sore it was like like I'm so sore
so I thought the same thing I'm like
there's no better feeling than
complaining about being sore cuz that
means like you're so active but what
I've learned now now I work out like a
couple times a week once you're like
continuously active like you don't get
sore right so like complaining that
you're sore is actually just like making
people realize like you're not in shape
right and also like it just means you
don't stretch and I don't stretch who
the [__] has the time no one I don't
have time I first of all my workout
journey is was really bad today I was
supposed to workout before this
obviously I slept through it I don't
work out before anything it's always
after it's yeah I've also started doing
that yeah but I played volleyball in
high school so did I really what was
your position uh okay
bench the thing is like I loved playing
volleyball I was on for all four years
of high school and my senior year I was
on the varsity team and like I was just
getting like no respect like I wasn't a
captain I sometimes started sometimes
didn't I'm like you know what I'm not
spending my [__] senior year being
disrespected and I left the team after
four years and of course that's the year
they won the championship like it was
like I kind of have volleyball trauma I
also have volleyball trauma because I
men's volleyball is really crazy it's
crazy I was labera obviously they just
like what the [__] is that like the the
the short passer oh like the first hit I
was so bad that there was this eighth
grader that would not only always
obviously Play Over Me in the games cuz
I was benched but would play over me in
practice wow like that was like it was
it was bad why why I started just like
being like okay this like you know it it
hurts it hurts I'm like wait I'm really
that bad like I took it personally when
I wouldn't get like started right and
it's like why would they start me but
the thing is like I believed I was good
like I wasn't bad there were definitely
people who were better than me I wasn't
going to be like your first choice your
second choice you're fifth maybe yeah
like it was it was really hard for and I
started to take it personally and I did
and I'll stand by this I do believe my
coach had something against me and like
I know that she did so it it was part
like maybe I I didn't deserve to be like
100% the starter all the time but she
definitely had it had it out for me and
I I took my power back and I quit the
team I definitely started misbehaving by
the end of it as well yeah no I was
definitely also like chatting in
practice which was like a big no no oh I
was the most and I would act like I like
knew what was going on and everyone
would be like someone get this kid to
shut the [__] up yeah not not only does
he not shut up he's not good oo like you
know what I mean also like the drills
like the running and stuff like I just
felt like that was unnecessary like wtp
what's the point w a
w why are we running like NR no reason
no reason yeah NR I love that no reason
you're wearing some of your merch today
that says gag now I assume you're not
promoting [__] there's a a deeper
meaning let me oh I know what it is get
a grip get a grip I love that yeah I
love I just love ning I so you another
one of the trends that you really
created on Tik Tok is we're ning where
you just like make up an acronym instead
of saying a short sentence and it's
literally in my life me and Ben are
always doing that too it to so but like
we before we made the Tik Tac we're
always just like saying stuff I like if
we're like talking I said I feel like
such a big ugly loser he's like a BL I'm
like yes a I am a my
what that's funny like that's see it's
Nim is so fun cuz you figure it out in
the moment like what did I say earlier
STD so so I forget but now it can also
mean save the date save the date love
that like it could mean I think you said
sdt so damn true oh yeah so damn true so
damn true and then what's my favorite my
favorite is Tino let me think t i n o mm
this is not okay yes Dad it's not okay
it's and you can like conjugate it so it
can be they are not okay or that is not
okay
that is not okay yeah and then there's
also Tissa this is so awkward TSA no T
IA this is so awkward yeah I love that
yeah ilt I love that yeah IL IL yeah
iluso is my favorite what did that stand
for again I love the Uso bit yeah that
was sick and E show it's so hot outside
oh yeah well my I have a do I have I
don't have one here but it says ish it
can mean I'm so hungry it's so hot like
it just depends like you use it it
depends like in What scenario you're use
like if I was like outside and it was
90° i''d be like
is and they'd be like okay you're so hot
like it's so hot Ben's uh Nim that he
made up that he's really proud of is
myasus my shorts are too short he was
obsessed that's sick sick TS that's sick
Taylor Swift yeah that's sick like my
it's fun when like all your friends are
in on the Nim so like for you it's fun
that like Ben's in on it because like
we'll be just like oh like we'll say
like like we can say it without having
to ask what it is like we'll be like
what should we do for dinner and we'll
be like oh TT trying to think trying to
think like just give me act like TT or
we'll say tib tib is one we use all the
time let me think
tib
tib what are we having for dinner
tib I don't know this is bad this is bad
so like I'll sometimes like look at my
friends I'll be like holy [__] tib TI
like this is bad this is bad or Tisa
holy [__] Tissa this is so awkward I'm
obsessed with him I'm obsessed with you
you crushed your first time on the toast
oh did I you did thank you so much for
being here now before you leave I am
going to force you to make like 100 Tik
toks with me oh wait I was going to say
we need to make the October 3rd one we
need to go do a ning one yeah we need
obviously we're ning we're October 3rd
in and then do have others as well cuz I
no just those too okay yeah well those
are fire those are good enough yeah
those are good enough everyone make sure
to follow Jake on all social media
platforms he's on Tik Tok he's on
Instagram pass that post8 right no no no
Instagram [__] sorry Instagram is P that
pus and Tik Tok is octopus lover 8
octopus with two SES for puss yeah I
think doesn't octopus always have two
SES No One S no yep wow okay thank you
guys so much for listening to the T
Morning Show where we deliver the fast
five stories every Monday Friday you for
watching this on YouTube please to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up also available podcast any podcast
sptify
a beautiful siging and wickedly talented
we are hope you guys have an amazing day
we are back tomorrow with Jack so love
you
bye